The only rule
for eating a taco
is that once you have it
ready, you don't put it down.
You just finish it.
[LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I grew up in a
family where food was the glue
of everything, cooking, eating,
and sitting around a table
brings people together in
a way that few things do.
I never set out
to become a chef.
I opened a restaurant, and it
was a farm-to-table restaurant
in Mexico City when that
was not the general trend.
It was so successful that
I turned it into my career.
This class is for
everybody and anybody
who's interested in food.
It's important to know about
other cultures through food.
I'm going to teach you how to
make a few delicious salsas.
Oh, my goodness, it's so good.
Pescado ala talla, tuna
tostadas, aguachile,
tamales, and I'm going to teach
you how to make tortillas.
From age 7, I became the
resident tortilla maker
in my house.
It was the first thing
I learned to cook.
It's actually a
fairly easy process.
There's nothing like
a fresh-made tortilla.
There really isn't.
We're going to make tacos al
pastor, the dish of Mexico
City.
And it's a street food.
It's a rub with chiles,
fresh vegetables, and spices.
The aroma is really enticing.
That is so good.
It's very typical
of Mexican culture
to start the day off with eggs.
We're going to make huevos
rancheros divorciados,
using a green sauce
and a red sauce.
I'm going to put a
little bit of water.
They're going to roast
for half an hour.
And meanwhile, we do nothing.
[LAUGHS]
I really urge you
to pay attention
to every bit of what you
put into the dish, just
in a way in which you
translate your enjoyment.
Está delicioso.
And I know it's not always
easy, but the more one
can connect with
people over a shared
love of a delightful dish, the
better off your result will be.
I am Gabriela Cámara, and
this is my MasterClass.